this question is from jake uh
the question is it's curious to hear
about uh
evidence regarding different types of
liquid carb sources intra workout so
sometimes this individual jake trains
for over two hours in brazilian jiu
jitsu has been trying a poly
polysaccharide product made from potato
rice and corn
and this is something that really got
big in the fitness world these kind of
designer carbohydrates and highly
branched cyclic dextrin exactly you'd
hear about these products high molecular
weight carbohydrate you'd hear about
molecular weight that was always a big
selling point and they talk about the
exact branched structure of the the uh
the starch polymer of a particular
product
um
i gotta be honest i i did uh publish one
study on uh kind of like designer
carbohydrate back in grad school at that
time i had looked into the literature
and
i had never seen anything that was
particularly uh spectacular from some of
these designer carbohydrate products i'd
never seen anything where i was like wow
that is a huge deal and makes a big
difference uh i haven't revisited that
literature in detail in a while but i
honestly don't think you can do much
better than a very simple
six to eight percent carbohydrate
solution
the total amount of carbohydrate you
would ingest ultimately depends on the
volume and the intensity of the work
that you're doing and of course by
extension the duration as well
so i mean you know
30 grams an hour maybe up to 60 grams an
hour unless you're doing really
prolonged really intense stuff that's
usually plenty to get you through
uh and when it comes to like i said a
six to eight percent carbohydrate
solution as a beverage
i think you know
if you're only having like 30 grams per
hour
the exact source of carbohydrate doesn't
really seem to matter that much
but if you're the more that you ramp up
your intake in grams per hour the more
you have to think about transporters in
the gut and so glucose and fructose are
transported a little bit differently so
when you start really pushing the carbon
take intra workout you have to consider
what's going to be
very efficiently taken up into systemic
circulation you also have to consider
what's going to be
easier on your gut in terms of reducing
gi distress so that that's why i do like
to have a liquid
source of carbs in order to get around
some of those considerations a really
simple way to do it is to have a ratio
of approximately two to one when you're
considering your carb source and
thinking
in the digestion process what simple
sugar is this going to end up being
before it's absorbed
usually a ratio of two parts glucose to
one part fructose is a good place to
start
and so
what i mention here six to eight percent
carbohydrate approximately two to one
ratio of glucose to fructose you're
going to find similar stuff
in pretty
pretty much any commercial sports
beverage that isn't like the special
zero or low carb version so if you were
to just get like a regular
gatorade or powerade or whatever it is
big these days
it's probably going to be pretty close
to fitting these criteria and this is
pretty much what the evidence would push
you towards so for me personally if i
was i know it doesn't sound very
interesting or sophisticated or nuanced
but like if i was going to do some stuff
that needed some intra-workout carb
i'd probably grab a gatorade uh and
i think there's probably a reason why
like in high-level sport that is
a very common way to go with it
have you looked into any of the research
suggesting that if you consume highly
branched cyclic dextrin during your
workout uh the increased gains you're
going to experience will be quote
nothing less than shocking
no where was that published uh t nation
okay on on the plasma sales page
so
uh whenever i think about this stuff i
always think about the t nation uh
sales campaign when they launched plasma
their reactive pump supplement
so uh let's just read from from these
research findings that they that they
published on their sales page
the plasma formula also contains highly
branched cyclic dextrin which is a
specialized carbohydrate that
significantly increases metabolic rate
and performance levels research shows
that highly branched cyclic dextrin
benefits athletes in these powerful ways
increases vo2 max in time to exhaustion
and elite swimmers makes intense
exercise actually feel easier decreases
stress hormone levels following
exhaustive exercise provides rapid
hydration and nutrient loading without
increasing gastric emptying time and
increases endurance to fatigue by 27
over glucose supplementation and doesn't
spike insulin in comparison
taking timed plasma doses before during
and after training loads the muscles
with key anabolic nutrients aka glucose
for maximum i say aka glucose no that's
okay i'm ad-libbing i'm i'm riffing yeah
uh
for maximizing performance and enhanced
recovery the term for this the term so
here here comes some specialized
some specialized jargon the term for
this muscle engorging effect is called
the quote reactive pump
the reactive pump makes muscle hyper
responsive to nutrient uptake and hyper
responsive to growth signaling it also
provides you with unbreakable
performance in the gym and competition
by uniquely pre-loading and pumping key
nutrients into muscle plasma doses
enable you to perform at
and beyond your limits there are no
limits you can exceed them now
uh while recovering so fast you'll be
excited to go back to the gym not only
that the increased gains you're going to
experience from plasma pulsing will be
nothing less than shocking
so anyway um
i mean i think i think they published
this research
back in uh
like [ __ ] 2011 or something it was a
blind spot you're
you might be you might be a little bit
behind the the cutting edge empirical
findings here
fair enough uh we will teach it as a
controversy then dude i i loved
i think we've talked about this before
one of my soft spots is i love
supplement marketing i think it's i
think it's so [ __ ] funny and that
that area or that era of t nation was
the best yeah because like
first they come out with anaconda
delivering the anabolic load i don't
need to spell out the subtext there but
it was basically just like what if we
put together every supplement we sell
into a protocol where like your
supplement
your supplement stack per workout is
gonna run you about eight bucks or
whatever and it's like oh okay that's
shameless shameless cash grab very funny
marketing what you got next what they
had next was indigo 3g which is a
basically a blueberry extract that they
were treating as if it was like a state
secret where like the early buyers they
uh
sent them a single bottle and like a
special kevlar case
um
so that that was a very funny rollout
for something that that was just like an
anthocyanin extract uh and then the the
end of this golden era of biotest
marketing was plasma which is literally
just like a starch supplement that
they're just and and most of the
marketing leading up to it was just like
they they'd take prominent individuals
in the fitness community and
somehow get them to say man i've been
training hard and
i've been growing a lot of muscle more
than i expected and somehow
i'm getting too lean i can't stop myself
getting leaner i'm consuming effectively
sugar throughout my entire workout and
somehow i just can't stop getting
shredded yeah uh
god that was
that was the best they've really they've
really fallen off i don't know how the
business is doing but
uh they have not made as audacious of
supplement claims recently and honestly
i miss it i yeah my i have a
biotest new supplement launch
sized hole in my heart yeah that can
only be filled by a new completely
audacious biotest supplement their next
one was brain candy which
was basically just like a
like basically like a five hour energy
with some feeling in it and like i'm
sure it was fine but like
it wasn't as funny there were no
anabolic loads being delivered yeah um
the the marketing wasn't as over the top
so
uh tc if you're listening to this
hit us with some more of the crazy [ __ ]
double down i need the crazy [ __ ] i need
i need the anabolic load 2.0 yeah um
anyway so i will say i missed the days
when because all that stuff was hitting
when we were like young and i i remember
getting ripped off uh from all the
supplement claims from various companies
but at least it was at least i had hope
in my heart you know i would buy like i
would literally literally switch from
one pre-workout to another pre-workout
that had a virtually identical set of
ingredients and i'd be like maybe this
is gonna be my secret weapon you know
like maybe this is what puts me over the
over the hump here
i very much do miss that type of
optimism
and of course the entertainment value is
exceptional